hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
it's about to go down
and by down I mean my chance of survival
oh hey algae that's helpful I'm not
getting any new duplicants for the
immediate future I'm just gonna get some
goodies that they're gonna give me and
then I'm gonna go do something else um
so I'm gonna start small I'm gonna start
with just and I mean rules the beginning
phases and then see where that goes
because this is all gonna rush down here
and then once maybe I should dig this
first I will dig that first we're gonna
dig a tunnel from here to right cheer
and once they do that then we're gonna
dig that up there so I'm gonna let them
go for that they've been going to full
speed for a while now I guess well they
haven't died yet so I guess everything
is gonna so I'm just gonna let them go
for a bit and then once they're good
with that we move on to Phase two of our
wonderful smart genius big brain plan
but when I made this algae thing I felt
like it was a good idea the whole way
through
now when I'm making this other thing I
guess I just got this bad feeling like
the whole time so I just feel like it's
just gonna go very very poorly it's
gonna go absurdly poorly like there is
no limit to the amount of bad that is
gonna happen here Oh oops well they
can't do anything else because I'm again
I'm very dumb maybe it's not a bad idea
maybe it's gonna it should work like
what it should do and what it's probably
gonna do is they the water's gonna flow
down it's going to melt
whoa oh he can't you woke it ooh
Nick and you Nick it you get out of
there Nick yeah it's you get
gather pencil oh god you can't you can
either oh god oh
[ __ ] choo choo choo oh my god you
almost died oh god get a bed get him a
cot get get here's here's Nick here's
our cot priority yellow on the car Iike
qu- medical building outside of a
hospital get it anyway what we're no get
no please get back in you know maybe
it's because it's not in a hospital I
guess I don't know it's gonna be a tiny
Hospital right here we're gonna make it
you could you know me toilet Oh boil it
mess table medical equipment oh alright
you know what actually this is stupid
why are we building it here when we
could build it right up here what have I
done what do I done I mean I'm an
[ __ ]
Oh God I have really goofed this really
hard but you could you got the job done
which you know you got a you got a
respect you got to respect that because
that that's worthy of my respect I feel
bad I feel really bad don't know trust
me I feel bad about it but we're still
worthy of my respect so I I definitely
respect it Oh God and you know what
actually I could probably make a make a
oh here and then there's gonna be it
needs what it needs medical equipment so
we need this we need the the mess table
toilet and that's it right
turlet it's gonna be an outhouse but you
know it'll it'll it'll be separate that
a little bit turlet and then I'll put a
deodorizer there just so oh god you
could chew you're still working oh you
brave soul you through so oh my god go
life supports apply to you could chew
life support for yourself yeah maybe you
should yeah you should do that life
support for yourself you you supplying
critical materials for life support yeah
you you could you you gotta go you gotta
get
you gotta go you gotta go you can see
you gotta get healed oh oh oh
ER coode ye oh ye ouch
oh there you go there you go
he who is oh you're doing research on AM
aren't you you're experimenting where
are you shoving that thermometer I don't
even want to know tell me in great
detail where are you shoving that
thermometer I don't want to know it's
too cruel but do it in sign language so
I don't suspect a thing
come on you can tell me you can trust me
I'm not watching you catch you my heart
bleeds for you you could chew you're
such a kind soul all right while you're
healing up we're gonna enact a plan
roaring magma that's what this plan is
called because it's so good at coming up
with plans
all right so operation roaring magma
will be underway in just a hot second
get it a hot second it's cuz it's gonna
be real hot and this might destroy
everything so operation roaring magma is
gonna be underway real soon real soon
put a wash basin or something here why
is this no power needs to be so much
more power oh hey are you done healing
or something why don't you get back in
your bed oh wait I see a mistake I the
hole you're eating with food poisoning
all you're gonna get food poisoning
you're gonna get sick that's not the
best thing in the world yeah I know it's
it's black go to sleep going into bed
whoo she could chew I do feel bad
you could choose like my favorite or you
could chew I'm sorry that that happened
I'm sorry
you okay you're okay right
you're okay the decor sucks in this
place I know I didn't have time to put
molding in there but you're okay well we
need you better because you're the only
one that can do operation roaring magma
I'd have to get evil babyface to do it
and I know you don't want that maybe I
should I guess evil babyface really
wants to do the digging so I could let
evil babyface do it I you know actually
I'll it's okay if we lose evil babyface
it's not the worst thing in the world I
guess all right he who sure does love
the art I guess but that would put you
over your your morale requirement which
we're not gonna do you are so morale
you are very morale dup your morale high
exosuit wearing I guess tinkle tush you
get mechanic with trips
you'll get tidying and that'll put you
even Steven and I you know he who I
would but I got a you can't I mean you
could choose already getting pretty
stressed decor and there's just abysmal
sorry you could chew it I really wish it
wasn't like down get you a nice Rock and
I'll put a I'll put up I won't put I'll
put a crown molding and corner molding
and I'll make it kind of nice all right
evil baby face Oh God evil baby face if
you use this as an opportunity to enact
your evil plan and destroy us I will
never forgive you ooh yeah yeah you get
that who you're getting real close to
actually doing the thing so just uh
beware this is it oh god oh god this is
it I'll pop deer drum as well where are
you going where are you going
what oh god it's happening
okay here we go here we go okay here we
go and steam okay steam is happening
what's the temperature doing
Oh temperature's going fun temperature's
going real funky
okay not not a lot is happening
I expect this to be like I'm a lot more
like explosive oh that's some hot steam
that's some hot steamy steam that's
that's okay I guess this is actually
quite underwhelming uh if if I do say so
myself this is a lot more underwhelming
than I thought it was gonna be I had
initially suspected like a more
explosive reaction this is a lot
different than I suspected which is fine
I guess I guess yeah it's fine or if
it's cooling any of this then it is
cooling it down
oh it's cooling it down wait a minute
could this actually be working I would
there's no way this is actually working
to help me is operation roaring magma a
success did operation roaring magma
actually freaking work did operation
roaring magma actually help me to reduce
oh my god it's going down operation
roaring magma is a roaring success and
you could chew as you're healthy and
free we have done it we have not
exploded an operation roaring magma is
dropping the temperature Oh like a dream
like a dream like a dream whoa okay the
steam just condensed which is
interesting because it's acting like a
plug right here because this is so
narrow it really is just acting like a
weird plug which I'm all about like
that's cool I'm down with that
okay cool so what I got to do is I got
to get more water funneled down this way
okay what are we getting this is what
saltwater why would I
vole pump eat the regolith collected on
terrestial surfaces get some salt water
I guess okay all right cool salt water
all right cool anyway uh this is
fascinating because it worked it really
worked
okay that's heating up and cooling down
in weird ways temperature's going all
funky all over the place but like it
actually worked at least you know it may
not end up with like making everything a
hundred percent great but at the very
least it didn't blow everything up and
it is actually purifying the water and
it's not even dirty
kind of knocks a few of my requirements
out of the park but I got a hurry up now
because if I don't get more water right
now it's it's game over so I'm just
gonna punch this hole straight through
there get that water I know it goes
right through slime but frankly I got
nothing actually let me do this going
because it's just a little bit badder
gonna do that there get some of that
water going in there and then hopefully
hopefully god I need this needs to be
powered like that's that's like a it's
like not just a suggestion it's it's
kind of a must at this point because if
I don't have the power for that it is
just it's so game over it's so game over
because I need water I just have to have
water and I don't want to put another
coal generator there even though we need
coal generator there okay I'm gonna
approach it from two ways I'm gonna get
this go down this is gonna go down this
is gonna go down and then bada bing go
bada boom bow bottom that's a lot of
steam and I can't go in there or else
things will get absolutely death
everyone who goes in there will die a
horrible horrible death okay good yeah
good good sopping wet
mee-mah you better wash your hands when
you get it when you get back in you've
gotta wash your hands nicely done meemaw
you got it I believe in you okay here we
go
punching the new hall here we go all
operation roaring magma it's going down
it's going down I mean it is is in fact
going down how soaked not gjermund at
all your fine actually
okay operation roaring magma adding more
water to the new area hey it's actually
breaking that down which is concerning I
don't know why but that's getting broken
a little odd but very interesting it's
like it's acid and it's dissolving it
which is oh look at the little baby PACU
oh look at the little baby bug ooh are
you doing over there are you doing good
you're so cute you're probably gonna die
from the intent to eat but you're so
cute okay maybe the reason that's
cracking is not so much that the acid is
devolving it but this is becoming so
over repressurized
that it's pushing and the only weak
point that it has and thank goodness
this insulated tile is not the weak
point but that's that's an indicative
sign that
this is a building time bomb that's a
pressure I built a pressure bomb and I
think it's gonna blow it at any moment
so just had to look forward to okay I'm
gonna put this back down to you normal
that's going down now we're getting a
good bit of water here it's still
steaming it up it's not exactly
condensing very much but that's okay
that's okay this is all good this is
good this is going well hey did I finish
ranching I did I did finish ranching
alright you know actually I'm gonna flip
this so that the door is on the top for
this be the critter area because that
way they can't actually escape I don't
know if anyone's actually gonna be able
to get through all right maybe nevermind
because I don't know if that's gonna
work how about I put it one up that
seems good one up is good I like one ups
everybody loves one ups one ups are the
best so food quote-unquote food to
critter drop off plop them right there
critter feeder right there airborne
critter bait fish feeder okay well I
don't need that what about a grooming
station
I need a grooming station hearing
station grooming station grooming
station bada-bing shearing station I
don't know if we need that but I have
that so that's good this still hasn't
been done but it's unreachable that's
why okay
operation roaring magma now has a lot of
water right there so that's good unless
it's not good oh I have a tea salad as
is Aitor
I completely forgot about my
desalinization I need desalinization how
much desalinization can I do
desalinator how big is this is big but
it'll go right there it'll be perfect
okay that'll be perfect right there
I'll have this go down I'll go down here
unless that's too hot it's a little
spicy but I think it's tolerable if we
insulate it maybe you know maybe we
should go through this way because
that's that's a lot cooler it's a lot
germy or oh it's not it's not germy
that's clean slime who thought okay so
this is how this is gonna go gonna have
a door here but it does good for the dog
a baby flood it does it does
great there's a guys are here we could
explore what is that it's probably gonna
kill me I bet that's gonna kill me dead
great okay insulating tile bunk bunk and
then we're just gonna go ladder down to
here we're gonna dig out point point
point point point point point point
point point point point no more than we
need you and boy boink and ladder down
into the ocean boom splash done once
we're in the ocean it's too wet I say
ocean it's just salt water that's all it
is so what we're gonna do with that is
everything we're gonna make it we're
gonna make it guys this is gonna work
guys it's gonna work we got food we
don't have water but we got the stopgap
measure to get water we've got the
temperature soaking it it's gone down a
lot it's gone down quite a bit it's gone
down quite a bit it hasn't gone down
that much where it needs to go down but
it's going down quite a bit and like
this that's kind of it's kind of not
really but it's kind of helping it's
still it's toasty there 28-point see I
don't think that can live past 30 mm
it's not good we need I know I know we
get ice by making ice but how do we get
is bigger it makes so much heat though
Oh No
we could put the heat maker outside I
guess oh I've done that before and it's
gone horribly wrong oh but let's do it
anyway
it's weird putting the ice maker down
out in the super hot area but hey
whatever in the effort of not making it
in just a pure heat box maybe I should
think about this a little better I just
don't know anymore and I don't know if
it's gonna be able to cool anything down
how much heat does it pasta could it
possibly dissipate I don't know that's
the thing all right you know I won't
know until I do it because I have no
idea how this works so I need to just
find out how it works before I can even
do anything else so I just I have to so
let's just make it and you know we'll
see what happens
when it happens and if it's bad then I
will at least have learned something and
if it's good then I will have learned
something so I'm just gonna do it
because frankly the term Yolo might be
dead because it jumped off of a building
screaming its own name but at least I
have a chance to do something yo licious
right here right now I think I don't
know I shouldn't feel proud of anything
that I said in that sentence there oh
hey oh operation
roaring magma is back in effect
operation roaring magma still going
strong baby still going strong that's a
lot of steam that's breaking everything
oh my god there's been no decrease in
temperature in any of this it's just
only been increase it's only higher
which is great I love that and I also
forgot that this recycling water
actually heats up the water and that's
another problem because that's why
that's getting warm is because going
through the water sieve actually does
make the water warmer it is pretty warm
right here that's not good
I've never really been good at getting
the temperature down on these things but
you know hey it's all okay
unreachable dig I don't know why that
doesn't seem right it should be
perfectly reachable I I'm gonna put a
bit of a priority on this because I
think we're gonna burn alive if we don't
get this right quick you know right on
the quickly split
of things if I'm not on the quick and
east side of things we're gonna probably
get it where'd that water come from
excuse me what how oh that
mmm that's problem unless it's not its
problem
okay mop that up like I guess things
were going very wrong guys I I wish I
could say that I had things under
control but the truth of the matter is I
do not Hey look at all those those are
cool bubbly bubbly bubbly oxygen
icemaker good okay how do we do that can
we get this at a level six priority I
just want to see what it do I don't know
if there's gonna be enough time in the
day to get this to go man all these
ladders are killer like that's really
what's destroying this I could get the
poles going yeah if I could get the
poles going that would help a little bit
poles are here I don't know what they
called if they cost refined metal oh no
oh no well I gotta get it eventually
that's not good that's filling up pretty
tight that's not what you want to see oh
good great how about some cool there we
go got some cool lump of coal I feel
good about this hey you make a nice oh
you are warm oh you are warm
this is a bad idea this is a bad idea
there's no ice biome around nothing but
heat hot hot heat
everywhere you look just more hot heat
and then whatever this is which is
probably with my luck it's gonna be a
volcano and I'm going to die and ice
write as- sorry that's doing ice is made
germs are dying that's good
so the germs are either getting roasted
alive or they're being frozen okay any
minute now
ice ice hey I say good I'm a phone
there's ice which is great and it's it's
ice now can you get the ice or else it's
gonna you know get warm and then it's
not gonna be ice anymore
wait the ice makers now in 33.4 because
the ice cooled it down wait y-you need
50 kilograms of ice really Oh God okay
where did you put that ice where's the
ice oh you're just keeping it in there
Oh interesting so honestly that doesn't
make that much heat because it cools
itself down after it's done that's very
interesting that's different than I
thought it would be and frankly now I'm
not so scared to keep that where it
needs to be but that doesn't mean that
I'm just gonna recklessly go willy-nilly
Wapping them everywhere
the second but it's still pretty decent
so I'm gonna put who are those bad boys
right here in addition to that one up
there oh there you go 60 kilograms of
ice and then there goes the temperature
goes way down so it does make heat but
then it goes right back down maybe the
ambient temperature maybe I'm being
crazy about thinking that the ice inside
isn't cooling it off because that
wouldn't make much sense because then
the ice would be warming up I think this
is going down to the ambient temperature
no I think it's going down this is
thirty two point eight is now lower than
the surrounding material
interesting very very very interesting
you know actually I might I might
actually make more of these bad boys oh
you can put it over you can put the
tiles over you can put the tiles over
things that you were gonna I love that I
love that I love that it used to be you
couldn't put hot you had to wait until
the the things were done being destroyed
before you could put them over that I
love that that's pretty good okay we
still got a heat problem but if we cool
the air before it gets pumped and
distributed to the rest of the area it
should result in a net cooling probably
not because of the laws of
thermodynamics said that I can't just
make ice and then blow ice everywhere
and then suddenly it's all hunky-dory
and better but you know it's pretty cool
so what I'm gonna do with that one is
I'm gonna build this to supply power to
no that's the wrong is the wrong
subsection is gonna supply power to this
which is gonna supply power to this one
yes and then I need to make more battery
for that so I'm gonna put battery oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I owe
Frick steam vent oh god oh god no God no
God no God I'm just gonna wall it up for
now I don't have time to think about you
I don't know when you're gonna blow but
just keep it all inside of yourself and
don't bother me with it
someone mop this up oh we got so many
problems oh we've got so many problems
oh this is bad that's getting full up
that's got no power
I need more batteries for that fricken
they're gonna go up here down down down
down this is not ideal right now it's
not cash money this is the opposite of
whatever cash money is it's it's uh
change dinero's it's just it's not good
it's not what you can call good okay so
there's a lot of things that need to be
done before this all goes to [ __ ] but
for now at least it's okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna turn these off just because I
can't have this overflowing
or else it'll ruin everything they got a
dig up here and then they're gonna put
this here at least we're getting ice
we've got 90 kilograms of ice I don't
know if they put any in here no they
have not
I'm gonna make another one there's
probably a waste okay I'm gonna walk
away because I can't look at this and
you're gonna just follow you could chew
around cuz he's he is the most cash
money that's evil baby face I was
mistaken okay you're gonna keep an eye
on evil baby face cuz I just don't trust
evil baby face we did oh it's beddy-bye
time okay well this was an awkward time
to come back did evil baby face do
anything evil probably okay nothing has
changed absolutely nothing has changed
except this is getting explosively large
levels of steam which is great at least
it hasn't burst through I guess we got
water
so that's decent whoa what what look at
you look at you I'm gonna drain your
habitat right out you're gonna have
nothing you make row as in fish egg
delicious delectable fresh egg I really
got a ranch some things okay what do you
take 60 well I don't need a shearing
station critter ranching skill uh who we
just researched something who among you
good old dumpling how about good old
dumpling loves critter ring ranching
what about you you're supposed to love
critter ranching while you don't now
you're gonna go back to farming get back
to farming you're gonna critter wrangle
you're gonna critter ranch that's what
we do here that's how we do it we're
gonna critter ranch and you're gonna I
don't know what we're gonna get some
Hatcher something actually let's put all
the hatches and hatchlings let's go for
hatches first cuz I know what hatches
need and let's put food for hatch and
hatchling perfect okay and we'll worry
about that later because we don't
actually need any power for it good old
dumpling you're gonna ranch hard if
you've got ranch you get ranch I'm gonna
put evil baby faces priorities back to
neutral for digging that's
we do your and I'm gonna put yours up
for farming I know you don't want to be
one but I don't care now I just gotta
find where the hatch sir I mean maybe
they're all dead so there's always that
possibility Oh an egg Oh a hatch there's
one okay so I just need to put a door
there and then sweep how's the temp
doing bad oh it's bad
oh it's bad all right it's real bad uh
how much ice is in here 50 kilograms so
that's pretty okay I know I go into
yellow alert a lot but let's just yellow
alert some of this and I just want to
see what happens no this one's on none
happy why are you unhappy popped
eardrums yeah whatever deal with it oh
that that works a lot better how much
ice is it using oh it's using a lot of
ice it's about to turn to water still
that's pretty good that's not bad
it's really dense with oxygen in there
we don't need this many maybe I should
turn some of these off that's nice and
chill that's superb Lee chill that's ah
quite chill in fact that helped I don't
know how long that will have helped for
but that helped okay I don't want a
bullpup but I bet they got great meat so
I'm just gonna take you right there and
hey let me stop you right there mr. vole
where are you where are you mr. dairy
are all right there's a bull and kill it
kill it kill it kill it destroy it no
[ __ ] we need to put door back on there
no one's gonna kill it what the hell you
are too cute maybe we should wrangle no
I'm gonna kill you kill you you're a
tiny baby you're gonna die you're tiny
baby you get any minute now you're dead
you're dead you're dead yeah
and dead there's the delicious meat whoa
who's stressed why Turner so stressed
whoa
Turner hey whoa easy there what's going
on is popped eardrums god dammit look
okay I'll just turn some of these off
okay is that is that satisfactory is
that is that good a disabled building
we're gonna
somehow I'm gonna turn the algae off in
these we're gonna disable that's all we
got that's all that's gonna happen so we
just disabled them and that's that's the
long and the short of it good we're all
we're all good so what we've what we've
reached is we've reached a good point
where things aren't immediately death
but it's still getting very close we're
gonna tap this ocean here which is
bigger it's way bigger than I thought it
was holy [ __ ] it just keeps going okay
so there's a lot of saltwater here and I
can refine that I can be salinated which
means to take the salinization out of it
i I can deal with the the breathing
problem if I lose a bit of oxygen
because we were just so goddamn dense
and that's what's causing some stress
right now so that's a problem but the
ice is cool the temperature is not like
oh it it basically did nothing ah it's a
little bit cooler here so that's good
that is good the saltwater here is very
cold so I don't know why but okay cool
we're not dead which is the only thing I
can really say at this point we're not
dead but boy howdy are we trying so
thanks everybody so much for watching
how am i doing I'm not good I'm not good
are we good we're good we're good now I
think we're good so crisis ease averted
next stop sanitation stop some help so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye here
[Music]